The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today we're
going to talk about cooking
and stoves and
charcoal and then there
will be plenty of
time afterwards
to work on your project stuff.
Ken is here already.
[INAUDIBLE] is around here.
And Amelia will
be coming at 2:00,
so everyone has a
mentor to work with.
Yeah.
So we did the labs in reverse.
So charcoal, we did
the lab on Wednesday.
And even though
it's warmer today,
I think the rain would have
made it even less pleasant.
So I think that
was the right call.
So we'll go through
that a little bit more.
Yeah, and I just
explained everything else.
So let's start just by
talking about cooking
in developing countries.
So what do people cook and what
are their needs for cooking?
Soups.
Sweet potato.
And how do they
typically prepare that?
There's a wide variety.
But what are some of
the cooking things
that you need to be able to
do from an energy perspective?
STUDENT: Boil water.
PROFESSOR: Anything else?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that would be oven.
STUDENT: Grinding.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
Cool, what else?
Meat.
And what do you do
with meet energy wise?
I'm sorry?
Open fire.
Anything else?
So stew.
What else?
Rice.
And that would be--
is that captured here?
Yeah.
Anything else?
Beans.
STUDENT: Do you
need high pressure
for anything [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Pressure
cookers exist.
You don't see them a lot.
STUDENT: You don't need
pressure for anything, do you?
PROFESSOR: No.
OK.
So this is a modest list.
But some things
that are missing are
bread is a staple
in a lot of places,
whether it's a tortilla or an
Indian flatbread or-- yeah?
STUDENT: No, I mean,
I'm just wondering.
[INAUDIBLE] mentioned
the pressure cooker.
How do you cook meat
without a pressure cooker?
Like how would you
reach that temperature?
Like if you wanted
to cook it in water,
wouldn't the water just boil
if you don't pressurize it?
Won't it just evaporate
if you don't--
PROFESSOR: So most
people don't boil meat.
STUDENT: Oh, so they
don't need water
when they're preparing it.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So yeah, so
I'm not saying that--
this might be a confusing
way to present this.
I'm not saying that
every one of these
requires every one of these.
Just that these are some of
the foods that you're cooking
and these are some of the ways
that you're preparing them.
So I'm just trying to make sure
that all of these are captured
or that all the methods are
captured but not linking--
yeah, because I would
be reluctant to eat
boiled meat straight
without any other preparing.
Though I think cabbage and
corned beef and cabbage
is boiled.
So I think you can do it.
STUDENT: Vegetables.
PROFESSOR: Vegetables?
Yeah.
Yep.
So meat is kind of uncommon
on most people's staples.
So you get it infrequently.
Rice and beans or other combos
that make whole proteins
are pretty common.
And a lot of people
live on rice and beans
pretty much every
day of their lives
with some tortillas sometimes,
in Nicaragua certainly.
Vegetables.
Oftentimes you grow some
vegetables and they supplement,
but you'll live on a
staple of rice and beans
a lot of where we're working.
And in terms of the cooking,
so for all of these,
there's the range
of you need low heat
or you could need high heat.
You can need an oven.
So talking about direct
fire hitting the pan,
hitting the food versus an oven
is going to be more convective.
And then-- yeah, and people are
pretty picky about the control
of their fire for most of
the-- or the heating source
for most of these options.
And so you'll see--
the people who
go to [? Grupo Fenix ?]
will definitely see this.
I don't know about
also [INAUDIBLE]..
But in [? Grupo Fenix, ?] a
lot of women or a few women
have gas stoves, but they still
maintain their old style adobe
wood because they will only
cook their tortillas on wood.
They just can't
cook on gas in a way
that they believe makes
an acceptable tortilla.
So that is one of the things
that I want to emphasize today,
I'm going to keep
coming back to it,
is that people
understandably are
very sensitive to how they cook
and have very long standing
traditions.
They are cooking the same
way their moms cooked
and their moms and their moms.
And so proposing to someone to
cook in a radically different
way is challenging and
is something people
are going to resist for
really understandable reasons.
So we've got the low heat,
the high heat, and the oven.
That sort of captures it all.
With boiling water, you
need high enough heat
that you can
actually boil water.
And each of those is
critical to most people.
You can't cook with 0,
with only one, ideally.
And so people who even just cook
on three stone fires with wood
just get really
good at regulating.
The oven is the optional
one that's the bonus.
But people who
cook with wood get
really good at regulating
their fire so that they
can get their low heat
or their high heat,
depending on what they
want, because most people
need to be able to do both.
So what fuels are
typically used?
Wood, yep.
[LAUGHS]
I'm not asking radically
crazy questions.
I think there's another one that
might come out in your mind.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yep.
STUDENT: Propane.
STUDENT: Kerosene maybe.
PROFESSOR: Some people also
cook with just general biomass.
So that might be corn
stalks or hay or similar.
It's not a great fire, but
if it's what you've got,
it's better than nothing.
Because one thing to
note on most of these is
can get away with not cooking
some of your vegetables
depending on how you
fertilize them if you did.
But you can't cook bread or you
can't skip cooking all of these
and expect to be
able to digest them.
So cooking is a non-negotiable.
It's our basic
human need, which is
part of why there's such a
high level of risk aversion,
because you're asking people
to change what they know
is the thing that's keeping them
alive and their family alive.
So some things to just keep in
mind generally about cooking
is that all modern fuel increase
with income except kerosene.
So people tend to
go from wood, well,
from dung to wood to charcoal
to propane and kerosene.
But then, well, to kerosene
and then to propane.
But people tend to stick
to propane for a while
because it's readily available.
And people get used to it.
In urban areas,
unsurprisingly, biomass
is less common than
in rural areas.
And in those rural areas, people
often just stick with biomass
forever because--
so even if you can afford
it, it's still easier
to get wood that you can chop
down basically in your backyard
than to go get propane.
So you'll stick with it.
And then another
thing to think about
is that even if people
have enough income,
if you can't get your
LPG or electric stoves
or whatever, if you
don't have electricity,
you don't have the
infrastructure,
you're not going to switch.
And then we often
think about what I just
said about going into your
quote "backyard" to gather wood.
But a lot of people in
relatively rural areas
purchase their wood
rather than collecting it,
either for time reasons
or because it's actually
there's so much deforestation
that it's really hard to get
the wood both in
terms of distance
and in terms of legality,
because often it's cutting down
wood on other people's property.
And so you are avoiding doing
the directly illegal thing
and just purchasing it.
It's less common in Central
America where we'll be going.
But in a lot of regions,
cutting down wood for fuel
is now a crime.
But there is no
alternative cooking method,
and so it still happens,
but now it's illegal.
And so it's become more
challenging in that respect
and more expensive.
In terms of how people
cook, it really ranges.
In places that have
similar levels of wealth,
you can see huge variations.
So there's LPG, electricity,
kerosene, and wood.
In Guatemala, whereas
here in Ghana,
wood is really used very
little and charcoal really
is used quite a bit more.
So it varies place to
place what people use.
And a lot of that has to do
with how far away the wood is
and therefore how expensive it
is and a lot of other factors.
But you should not assume,
this goes back to week one,
everyone cooks with wood
in a developing country.
It's very location
specific and even location
within the country specific
what people are doing.
The challenges with
fuel are that it
can be up to a third of people's
income just to pay for fuel.
And a third of your
income is kind of insane
if you imagine spending a
third of your income on fuel.
The poorest people in
the US are the ones
who are paying the most
are paying less than 1%
of their income on cooking fuel.
So if you imagine
going from something
that cost you 1% of
your income to 30%,
that's getting
really substantial.
And people who are collecting
it are sometimes in some areas
spending up to seven hours
a day collecting firewood,
which is basically the
same impact on your family
that if you're spending
seven hours a day,
you're not having any
time to do anything else
but get enough fuel
for cooking your food.
And then just
looking at the energy
densities of all of these.
So wood charcoal
and the charcoal
that we made on Wednesday is
very similar to wood charcoal.
You can get really
good wood charcoal
that's better than ours
and you can get really
junky wood charcoal
that's worse than ours.
So we're about in
the middle there.
Everything else
that's a biomass,
because it's not
compressed and/or processed
is going to be worse.
Dung is quite poor, both on
energy density as well as
health because you can
imagine burning dung is worse
than burning anything else.
And then heating oil,
all the things that we're
used to generally,
gas or electric, well,
electric doesn't
really fit in here,
but gas is certainly
a whole lot better.
And so of course,
people are going
to switch to here if
they can, but it's
expensive and challenging.
And just from a
visual standpoint,
these are all the cooking
options to think about.
So there's electricity,
propane, wood.
These are typically wood ovens.
Dung.
This is the Jiko stove that I'll
show a little bit later, which
can be used with charcoal.
There's cooking,
and then there's
a variety of different cooking
stoves that you can cook with.
And then this is just
a three stone fire.
So you can see there's three
stones here to support your pot
and then you feed your logs
in this way to cook your food.
So that's just a quick
overview on cooking.
We're going to get into it more.
But I wanted to switch gears
and do a quick estimation.
And it says in teams of two.
If you want to do it in three
or four, that's fine too.
But what's the energy required
to boil a liter of water
and what's the
efficiency to do so?
Go.
Yeah.
So I want to talk a little bit
about design considerations
for stoves.
Some of you may be
working on those projects.
So what do you think
you have to worry
about when you design a stove?
STUDENT: Air flow.
PROFESSOR: Air flow, yes.
Definitely.
What else?
STUDENT: Insulation.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
STUDENT: The environment.
PROFESSOR: The
environment you're in.
STUDENT: As in close
proximity, your environment,
making sure there is
nothing flammable nearby.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So safety.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yep.
STUDENT: Size?
PROFESSOR: Size?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Heat source.
PROFESSOR: Heat source.
STUDENT: Price.
PROFESSOR: Anything else?
STUDENT: Usability.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if you're cooking
outside, certainly.
I think I'm below the
magic line, aren't I?
Anything else?
STUDENT: Aesthetics.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
STUDENT: Convenience as in how
long it takes, time to use.
[INAUDIBLE] falls
under usability but
whether or not it's intuitive.
Usability is already
written [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: So it is.
All right.
Well, this is a good start.
To just give you a sense
of the list that I came up
with with another
person, there's
the insulation and
the thermal mass.
And this is actually
a complicated issue,
because in some cases,
like with an oven,
you want really, really
good thermal mass.
So you heat up that thermal
mass and then that thermal mass
allows you to cook longer,
whereas for a charcoal stove,
you don't want a
big thermal mass.
You don't want necessarily
0 thermal mass.
But if you have too
much thermal mass,
the charcoal will
use all its energy
in transferring it to the
stove and you won't be
able to cook very much with it.
Air flow is another
important consideration.
The reason the Jiko worked
so poorly on Wednesday
was actually because the
door never got opened.
That was my fault. I
realized that after when
I was cleaning up
then we never opened
the door, which meant
there was no airflow, which
pretty much limits the ability
of the fuel to get hot.
The volume.
So yeah, which we mentioned,
how much you're going to cook
is huge.
People have really
varying needs there.
Robustness to water.
So the Jiko, one of the
challenges with it is it's
made of ceramic, which makes
a really nice insulator.
But as we talked about,
if you pour water
onto it to prevent the--
to put out the charcoal, the
ceramic is going to crack.
And also if you drop it, the
But boiling water it's
pretty common for some water
to run over the
edge of the stove.
And so that alone
can cause cracking.
The cost of the device
is really critical,
as this is such a
fundamental need.
Everyone needs one.
And so if it's unaffordable,
that's pretty problematic.
Longevity is another concern.
A lot of these metal
stoves that I'll
be showing in a second don't
have a lot of longevity,
but they are affordable.
And so Paul [INAUDIBLE]
would be really
happy with that balancing act.
Other people would be less
happy, but it is an issue.
The heating options.
So ideally you could
have some magic stove
where you could use any fuel.
You could use charcoal or wood
or regular biomass or propane
or electricity or
whatever you could get.
You'd have this magic stove.
But that's not very realistic
from the price standpoint.
but people do like to be able
to cook with a range of fuels.
Ease of use is
definitely important.
If it's hard to light
or hard to keep the fire
lit or hard to get your pot on.
It's pretty unfortunate stove.
Emissions is another thing
to think about in terms
of where does the smoke go.
A lot of times it goes
straight into the kitchen.
You'll see in the
homes in Nicaragua,
the stoves look a lot like this.
And even when they
do have a chimney,
it's rare that all three holes
for the pots are covered.
And so the chimney
in that situation
doesn't work very well.
A lot of the smoke escapes.
Efficiency.
So how much of the heat
actually gets to cook as opposed
to doing something else.
Style, aesthetics are
all pretty important.
People do want their
Kitchens to be attractive.
And so while we're not
talking about a criteria
similar to does it look
like the stainless steel
kitchen in a high end kitchen
or a professional stove
in a high end kitchen
in the US, it's
still a really critical
thing to think about.
And a really junky looking
stove will not do very well.
And then flexibility for
cooking with different fuels
or different types of
foods, et cetera, et cetera.
So I'm just going to--
if we can turn it around
to go to the back corner
and show you a wide
variety of stoves.
So this is one of the
stoves we used yesterday.
And it's a pretty
simple wood stove that's
a relatively common design.
So you can see that it has the
upper surface for cooking with.
I'm not really sure
what these decorative--
if these are just
decorative or if there's
some purpose to them.
But it did prevent us from
using a certain pot yesterday,
so it was a frustrating element.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it might be to hold a
special type of pot, absolutely.
And then a place
to catch the ash
is pretty handy as well so
that the ash doesn't just
fall on the ground.
And it has plenty of holes
to allow for airflow.
The Jiko, These two
are called Jikos,
which is a design of a stove
that was developed in Africa,
in Kenya I believe.
And the Jiko has a ceramic
part that holds your fuel
and also acts as an insulator
and then metal everywhere else.
This one was not
made as carefully
and may be a knockoff
of this one, which
you can see the ceramic liner
is actually thicker on this one.
So it works a little better.
It has the door that allows
you to control airflow.
So that's a big improvement over
this one and the insulation.
It has these three
pieces, which allow
you to hold a smaller pot.
It has little handles that
may or may not work too well.
This is pretty heavy
for such small handles,
so I don't like actually
carrying it like that.
But it's a quite improved stove.
And in terms of efficiency, I
believe it cuts fuel use down
by like 30%.
So it's significant.
This is an interesting
stove that I don't know,
can you see this at all Eric?
OK, great.
So this is a knockoff Jiko.
And so you can see that it
kind of looks like the Jiko
but it's got a bigger door.
It has some really monstrous
handles that are actually
easier to use than those.
So that's a big improvement.
But it actually has so
much thermal mass in it
that it gets to that issue of
there's so much thermal mass
that you use all your
fuel heating the stove
rather than cooking.
And so it takes forever
to cook with this.
Like a ridiculous
amount of time.
And so it's one of those,
well, if this much insulation
is good, this must
be better assumption
that is really common.
We actually with our
charcoal we found
that if we make a charcoal--
that people like-- or
I'll talk about it more.
But a bigger piece of charcoal
that they can cut in half
and make into the same
pieces of charcoal that
are identical in size, but
they prefer the bigger size.
And same with stoves.
People tend to bigger is
better is the assumption.
These next four I'm going
to show our all stoves I
bought in Nicaragua.
So this one is cool
because it was a tire hub.
So a nice use of recycling.
These legs allowed
it to actually
be at this height,
which is pretty great.
However, for bringing
it back on the airplane,
I cut off the legs.
Mostly charcoal in
Nicaragua is used just
for frying up food at
places called fritangas.
And so they're just done
on the street corners
and as a sales thing.
It's rare to see these
in people's homes.
This is one, can even tell
what this is made out of?
So it's actually a gas cylinder
that got cut up probably
when it died.
And then rebar is the grating.
This one is really,
really simple
and just used out
of sheet metal.
It's galvanized.
So if you use it inside, it's
going to make people sick,
because the galvanized
metal gives off
fumes that are not so great.
And then this one is
an interesting design
that's pretty common,
usually made out of a--
it's usually bigger.
It's like a 55 gallon drum,
but I couldn't bring that home
on the airplane.
And this one is
interesting because it
allows you to use charcoal
or wood because you
can feed the wood in
this way like would
in a traditional adobe stove.
And so it's nice that it does
have that flexibility compared
to all the others.
And all of them
generally come painted
and then the paint all chips
away as you cook with it.
But that does speak to
the aesthetics interest
that people want to buy a
nice looking painted stove
even if the paint
doesn't last very long.
It helps them sell.
Yeah?
STUDENT: One of the
ones that we [INAUDIBLE]
last year was really easy
to make with sheet metal.
Is that really important
in a device or [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: So what
that team identified
was that it was
important that this
be made by the women locally.
And so therefore, they
decided that a single piece
of sheet metal was going
to be easier for the women
to make locally than making
it out of many pieces.
You as a team, if you end
up working on a project,
may come to a
different conclusion.
That's the conclusion
they came up with.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Do they have
access to welding?
PROFESSOR: So in
Nicaragua there's
plenty of people who well,
mostly with oxyacetylene
or stick welding.
But in the rural
villages, there aren't.
And so for example, in
where Grupo Fenix is,
there isn't a welder in the
village, in the community.
But if you went up to Ocotal,
you can find people who weld.
So there's definitely
welding capability.
You should consider that local.
But it's not something that the
women in the village could do.
And so that's why they didn't
come up with a welded stove
was because they wanted to be
something that the women could
do themselves.
So two really good resources are
cookstove.net, which goes more
into the theory of
cookstoves, and Aprovecho,
which is a huge organization
that does a lot of stove design
and testing.
And they have a lot
of great resources
about how to design stoves,
how to test stoves, et cetera.
Are there any other
questions about stoves?
OK.
So I'm going to talk
some more about charcoal.
So 2 and 1/2 billion
people cook with biomass.
So that's the market
we're talking about,
as opposed to people cooking
with gas or electricity.
And it's generally people living
on less than $2 or $3 a day,
though there is some
wide range on that.
And there's really no
viable alternative.
I'll talk about solar
cookers a little later.
Propane fuel is just
unavailable and same
with the grid in these regions.
And so cooking with biomass,
which I got into a little,
has some real problems.
So there's 1 million
and 1/2 people
who die every year from
indoor air pollution,
and that's generally
associated with cooking
inside the home,
smoking inside the home.
There's other things
that also contribute,
but indoor air pollution
from cooking is a huge one.
And it's mostly
women and children
who are the ones
tending the fires
and taking the biggest hit here.
So there was a study
done that estimated
that if everyone who currently
cooks with wood or dung
and straw and biomass that's
raw switched to charcoal,
half of those lives
would be saved right off
the bat with no added
ventilation, no other changes,
just switching from wood to
charcoal because it's that much
cleaner.
But then you get into
the environmental issue
of we're talking
about regions that
can be facing 6% to 10%
deforestation rates in areas
that are up to 98% deforested.
And so if you encourage
everyone to switch to charcoal,
you're going to be
using up more wood
and you're going to decimate
the environment even further.
And as I mentioned
before, there's
also a poverty aspect
to cooking fuel
in terms of how much
money and/or time it
takes to be able to cook.
So the charcoal that we
talked about on Wednesday
has some benefits in
that it burns as cleanly
as wood charcoal.
It's using a true waste.
The complicated part
about using a true waste
is that in every region,
some of the possible wastes
are not true wastes.
And so corncobs and stalks
can be used in farms
or any of these materials
to replenish the soil basically
except sugarcane, which
really has no nutritive
value once you
press the sugar out of it.
And so in places
where people are
using that to
replenish the soil,
it's a really bad
idea to encourage
them to switch to
making charcoal from it
because they're going
to decimate their land
and the land is so valuable.
However, in most farms that
are at the subsistence level,
you can find some
biomass that's rotting.
And so that's the
biomass we target.
So that's why we try
to have a process that
works with a huge
variety of waste
so that you can use a
wide variety of waste
and only use the
stuff that's waste.
The nice thing about
using the true waste
is that it tends to be
rotting in such a way
that it's producing a
lot of methane gas, which
is one of the worst
greenhouse gases
and worse for the environment
than burning the material.
And so they're actually areas
where you get carbon credits
just for burning sugarcane waste
rather than letting it rot.
And so here rather than
just helping the environment
by burning it, we're using
that fuel to cook with
as well as not getting the
methane in the environment.
So just to give you a sense
of where this project is,
so a few years ago, we
got a $200,000 grant
from the World Bank
to make charcoal.
And so we trained more
than 1,000 people in Haiti
in the method and we have some
workshops or ateliers in Haiti
that are making
the charcoal now.
Typically the costs associated
with the charcoal or just
the drum and the press.
And so the drum is anywhere
from $10 to $30 in a country
and the press generally
is about $2 to make.
If someone's telling you
they're going to make it for 10,
they're ripping you
off, so push back.
Because most people do
when you talk to welders,
most people talk about
how expensive it is.
But if you push, $2 is
a pretty standard price
we found almost everywhere.
So the process that we
went through yesterday
was we took the raw waste, wrote
it into a drum, lit it on fire,
covered it, then you're in an
anaerobic environment for about
two hours, and then you have
your charcoal finds, which you
crush in the bag in a bag
method and the rice husks mixed
with the binder made
from yucca, briquette it,
and then you can put
the briquettes back
in the drum to harden
them after they've dried,
and then you can cook with them.
So I just want to make
sure that you guys are all
comfortable with this method,
because you'll be doing it.
Most of you will be doing
it having only done it once.
And so I just want to make
sure you are feeling confident.
And so that's why I'm
reviewing it in so much detail.
So when you load
the drum, you need
to remember to have
the stick in the middle
to make your chimney.
You can use the fuses at the
bottom to help light the drum.
And it works really well to
light from the bottom rather
than the top.
If you just light
from the top, you'll
get much less effective burning.
When you're covering
up the drum,
again, first you see this smoke.
And actually, we saw very
little of the just white smoke.
We saw mostly yellow smoke.
The just white smoke is water.
And so if you're getting
a ton of just white smoke,
that means your
waste is too dry.
You're almost never going
to see it as dry as we had
on Wednesday, because that--
too wet, excuse me.
Too dry.
So you almost never see it as
dry as we had on Wednesday,
because that has been sitting
in a heated, incredibly
dry environment at
MIT for about a year.
And so that helps it
dry out at a level
that you're never going
to see in the field.
That's why it was
infected with cockroaches
because of all those--
because it was spending so
long in the bowels of MIT.
So you will see
some white smoke.
But if that's all
you're getting,
that's an indicator that
your stuff is too wet.
Or if the drum just won't
catch on fire at all.
And then you get
the yellow smoke
and then you get the
flame and then you
wait some period of time.
And I'm sorry I can't give you
a seven minutes answer for how
long you wait until you switch.
But things to look
for are remember
how it looked like this,
but then you'd get puffs.
Of the yellow smoke
and so you want
to wait until you're
no longer getting
those puffs of yellow smoke,
because those are areas that
haven't gotten any
heat yet that are now
starting to catch on fire.
And then later on what
cued me to cover it up
was we were starting
to get black smoke.
And the black smoke
tends to mean that we're
burning everything really fast.
And so that's why we
needed to cover it up.
But it is a judgment
call and it is tricky.
And so there's no easy way.
Everything from the humidity
to the temperature to the type
of the way--
what was in the drum before.
That's another thing
to think about is
if when you get an oil
drum, you don't know
where you're getting it from.
And so it may have oil in it.
And so you may need
to do like a pre
burn with just a
little bit of material
to burn out whatever
junk is in the drum
so that you have a clean-ish
drum to use for carbonization,
because you wouldn't want
oil impregnated briquettes,
because that would
burn pretty nastily.
And you can do side
by side carbonization
if you have a few
drums, which is nice.
And then covering it up, just
doing it relatively quickly
but also carefully
so you don't get
burned, because the drum is
really hot at that point.
For making the binder,
just remembering
that you're going for this
really snot-like consistency.
So checking and make sure
you get it before you use it.
Because if you
don't, the briquettes
will completely fall apart,
and that's problematic.
And then using the right
amount so that you actually get
a good briquette is important.
And then briquetting--
so I just wanted
to show you a couple of other
briquette press examples.
So the presses we used
yesterday are really simple.
And I'll talk about
how we got there.
But there's a cup, an
ejector pin, and a plunger.
And the block is
just because we don't
have tables with holes
in them around here,
but it's pretty easy to find
some of hole you can use.
So you don't actually
need a block.
But every team should plan
to bring a press with you.
And then ideally, you
can make them there.
But it's nice to have
one to show as an example
to your welder.
You can leave it
there if you need to.
In Haiti, our colleagues
got tired of making
one briquette at a
time, so they came up
with this press that
makes four at a time
and then has a plate that slides
out sort of like our old style
press that I'll show
you in a minute to make
four briquettes at a time.
The problem is you're
increasing the area,
so you're distributing
the pressure.
And so you really have
to wail on this press
to make briquettes well.
And 2009, they made
an extruding device
to make briquettes, which is
nice but a lot of material.
And just when you
briquette them,
make sure you're hammering with
enough force that you actually
get well compacted briquettes
or else they won't-- when they
dry, they'll fall apart.
So I want to talk a little bit
about how the briquette press
came to be, because I
think a lot of D-Lab,
you work on a project
and then you're done.
You hand off to the
community maybe.
And it seems like that's
all that it takes.
And at least in this case,
and I think in a lot of cases,
there's more required to
get to a good product.
So initially we made
briquettes just by hand,
as you can see in this picture.
And you can imagine compressing
that material hard enough
to get a really solid
briquette was pretty painful
on the hands, and
it really didn't
make very good briquettes
even if you were super strong
compressing the briquettes.
So then we looked at
buying a briquette maker.
And the mechanized ones that we
could find were about $8,000.
And it's entirely inappropriate.
And so there was a bunch of
work done by Jessica [INAUDIBLE]
to figure out the best method
for actually making briquettes.
And she honed in on
impact farming them.
And so she designed a
briquette maker here.
And so this is one of
the earliest prototypes
that had a handle.
Actually that's the
handle for the door.
Let me show you
the next picture.
I think it's easier to see.
So you load your
material in the top
and then it falls to the bottom.
This door is closed.
Then you put the plunger
in, close it with a pin,
hit it a few times,
and then when you open,
this plate at the bottom has
a pin sticking out the back.
And so it hits the back pin and
that pushes the briquette out
so you can grab it.
So it's a really nice design and
it made four to five briquettes
a minute.
So we were pretty happy with it.
But it was of slow
and frustrating.
And so the first improvement
was to do a time study
to figure out what was taking
so long and how to improve it.
And everything was
taking a long time,
but ejecting was
taking the most time.
Loading was taking a while.
And so someone that
Amy Smith worked with
came up with an improvement,
which got us to six
to eight briquettes per minute.
And so you can see that
some of the improvements
were instead of loading
from the very top, which
required a lot more precision,
you loaded from The side.
And for ejecting, instead
of having a special ejection
mechanism, which required
a lot of cleaning,
you just pulled this played out
and then dropped the briquette
down.
And then we actually--
well, actually I
can show you the presses.
They're over here.
So this one that you can see
down here, it has this plate.
And so the briquette
drops down there
like that plunger is trying to.
And then when you
close this drawer,
it actually pushes the
briquette out of the way.
So it's a little bit mechanized.
And so it helps speed
things up considerably.
And so we were
really happy with it.
But it was also a
relatively expensive design
because this plate
had to be quite thick.
And this is a really expensive
piece of metal just right here.
And so we were pretty
concerned about the prices
of some of these elements.
And so we had another person who
does a lot of work in Guatemala
take a look at it
and redesign it.
Unfortunately, I
wasn't able to find
one of these presses
in D-Lab today.
But he just made some
subtle improvements
so that that big
plate was cut down
until it was just as wide as
the diameter of this shaft.
And then everything else
was made with angle iron.
An angle iron is relatively
cheap and available everywhere.
And so that made it a
whole lot more affordable
for our partners.
Yeah, there are a
variety of changes.
And so you can see
just looking at it,
there's a bit less metal
here is the biggest change,
and that improved things a lot.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
fully solidified.
There's going to
be some loss there.
PROFESSOR: There is.
That was not, I would say,
very significant compared to--
actually this method, I think,
the method we have now is
there's more waste that
we just do it on the tarp
so that we collect that waste.
So we still weren't
happy with the price.
And so we ended up
radically redesigning it
by removing all of
the material basically
to just the most basic elements.
And we started with
a circular design.
And that still stands, but
we've also added a square design
so that if you have cylindrical
stock, you can use it.
And if you don't, if you have
square stock, you can use it.
One of the nice things
about square stock
is that it's a little bit
more flexible in terms
of these parts, the
two parts that you
need to fit into the press.
You don't need to
cut a careful circle.
You can just cut a square
and that's a lot easier.
And then same on the bottom.
You can just weld
these pieces on.
So we took that to the field and
we got a few different designs
back as improvements.
So this one is just used
sheet metal that's bent around
and then welded on the edges.
And so that further reduced
costs, because it's thinner.
It's a thick sheet
but not as thick.
And then this group used
angle iron you can see and put
four pieces of angle iron
together and welded the edges,
which requires a talented
welder, but if you have one
is a really nice
way to do things.
And so there's a whole
variety of little improvements
that are still being made.
But generally, we're very
happy with this press.
Now, it's interesting to note
that some of our partners
still prefer this press, as I
mentioned, because of the whole
bigger is better issue.
They just really like
this because they
feel like it's sturdier, even
though it's 10 times the cost
and has no additional value in
terms of speed or labor comfort
or anything like that.
So that's been one
of our challenges
is the people who
saw this press first,
they still want to use
it because they prefer it
despite the cost difference.
And so that's one thing
we're trying to work out
is how do we get that
cachet into this press that
is so much more affordable.
So all that said,
and this is a lot
of years of effort of
improving and improving
in small and big ways.
And so it's just worth thinking
about all the different ways
that a product
needs to be improved
past the initial prototype,
which is the stage that you'll
be getting to.
So I wanted to make a
couple of other comments
about running a training,
because you guys
will be doing--
at least two of the three groups
will be doing the charcoal
trainings in the field.
So just to start out
with, do you guys
have any questions
about how you'll
be running that training?
Have thought about
it at all yet?
How are you feeling
about doing that?
Yeah?
STUDENT: How do we know
what material [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So your mentor, your trip
leader has the contact
for your community partner.
And so you guys
should be in contact
with them to find
out what is there
and what needs to be brought.
And you should also be reminding
them right now that they
need raw material, the waste.
They should be gathering
that and drying it right now.
Any other thoughts or comments?
So just one thing
to think about is
what's the balance between
you doing a demonstration
and you having the people
there actually getting involved
and getting their hands
dirty and doing the work?
And how do you balance that both
from a pedagogical standpoint,
how do you help them learn
this activity the best,
and then also--
So making sure you have the dry
waste that's truly dry is huge.
Loading the drum, not getting
cut, because people often get
cut in that step.
Making sure you really
think before you light
the drum on fire is critical
as well as making sure things
are kind of calm
during the fire,
because oftentimes things
get a little hectic.
It's exciting when
there's fire and things
can get out of control.
And we've had issues where
a drum got knocked over
onto its side when we were
covering it up because people
were just too crazy.
And so it's not insanely
dangerous, but it is dangerous.
And so it's worth
just making sure you
have that under control.
Crushing is pretty
easy when you have
a big group because everyone
takes a turn jumping on the bag
and that's really nice.
Making sure you're going
to heat the water with--
if you're going to heat the
wider with the charcoal,
with the burn, make sure
you have that prepared.
Yeah, those are the big ones.
And then making sure
everyone gets a chance
to use the briquette press
because some people get really
into it and don't want
to give up a turn.
So making sure you do that.
All right, so the rest of the
class is just time for you guys
to work.
I want to remind you to
hand in these four documents
so that you can travel.
And then just don't forget
to do your [INAUDIBLE] cards.
Are there any questions before
you guys get into groups?
OK, cool.